hello everyone and welcome to game 9 of
the wheelchair championship match
between Yani pomishi and the dingler and
after the first eight games the score is
now four and a half points for nepo and
three and a half points for ding so nepo
is leading by uh by a full point and the
ding will now try to try to get back
into the match he already did it a few
times uh can he do it again uh last game
he almost did it with the white pieces
and we uh just when we thought that
every game is going to be a decisive
game because we've had four decisive
games in a row uh game eight ended in a
draw so let's see what happened in this
one and before we check it out here is
uh a nice photo of the ceremonial first
move uh being made by
um
he's the deputy chairman of the Assembly
of the people of Kazakhstan striking a
nice pose there very nicely done by him
uh so let's uh let's check it out uh so
Nepal with the white pieces opens with
Ponte E4 ending once again replies with
Ponte E5 with Knight to three Knight to
C6 and the bishop to B5 again and Nepal
state with the real Lopez and so far in
game one and in game five I didn't
continue with Ponte A6 and went for his
um uh well here of course wanted to go
for the Marshall nip always goes for the
anti-martial uh and now Knights the F6
we have the Berlin defense uh which is
uh very strong for black it's uh it's a
very uh I mean it's a very equalish
opening but then again uh you had that
candidates tournament where I believe
um I don't know who played it I I think
uh uh Levon Aryan played with with the
black pieces it was a spectacular
Victory with the Berlin defense that the
G5 idea maybe it wasn't Levon I just
can't remember but yeah I mean it could
go crazy but uh more often than not um
it it usually just ends up being a draw
in the year 2000 in the famous world
championship match between Gary kasparam
and Vladimir kramnik
economic used it four times during the
world's championship match the
sort of completely subdue uh of and he
was unable to do anything and in the end
he just kaspora just lost two games I
think game two and game ten and then
Kramden just became world champion so it
can do a lot but can can it give ding
the win or sort of a chance to bounce
back in the match let's check it out we
have Pawn to D3 uh Bishop to C5 now and
pawn to C3 with castles by both players
and now uh sorry castles and now usually
you will see these six here or Rook da
those are the top moves Rook d8 is the
top move D6 uh second most popular but
English for Ponte D5 and this is a sort
of a looking for adventure move Knight
beta D2 by nepo it's uh nothing new
really captures captures and now Pawn to
A5 and here uh a Magnus Carlsen even had
this position against uh Vladimir
kramnik and queen to C2 was played in
that game by Magnus the game ended in a
draw but here we have Ponte A4 it's uh a
bit of a more popular idea Queen to E7
and now Queen to C2 again not a new
position H3 is a known move Fabiano
caruana I played it against Levon
arunyan even though he lost that game it
was in lewden uh your next move
tournament in Belgium uh in 2018 but
here we have Queen to C2 uh by Yan and
now again a lot of popular options here
you could go Knight day seven to chase
away the bishop Knight to B8 Knight to
d8 basically night moves are popular
here maybe some H6 action here we have
Knight the B8 going back with the Knight
uh and now Rook to E1 just continuing
development nicely we have rooked the E
d8 by Ding and now Pawn to H3 just
taking away the G4 Square from uh ding
species with font H6 and now Knight the
F1 and again a known position Hikaru
Nakamura had it against Wesley so their
game ended in a rocky car just brought
back the bishop to F1 but here like I
said Knight to F1 we have Pawn to C6 and
now Bishop to C4 and here uh there is a
game uh we're not beat the D7 was played
um uh a game between Augustus morencanas
and Oliver cribonoso uh that ended by uh
that actually ended in a draw even
though they've had a bit of a large
difference in raiding uh the player with
the white piece was 1900 and the player
with the black piece was like 23.70 so
it was a great achievement for white but
here we have Knight to A6 and it is now
as of move 14 that we have a completely
new game and a completely new position
that has never been reached before and
this is basically where our game begins
uh we ignite the G3 by nipple and now we
have Queen to C7 and this queen to C7
move can be explained by uh checking
what happens if Bishop D6 is played
because you do want to continue
developing you don't want to move the
same piece twice in the opening uh it's
a very a very cool line because you're
kind of offering the E5 pawn and the
problem is if Knight captures an E5 now
Queen to C7 is problem for white as both
of the knights are hanging if you move
this Knight dangerous Queen captures and
G3 your F2 Pawn is pinned so here you
would have to play Bishop captures on E6
and after Queen captures on E5 there's
even a nice solution to the bishop
captures an F7 with check King captures
and now King H2 avoiding Queen captures
on G3 now King Jade and the game
continues but the black would have a
very nice game here however the reason
why uh this was not played is that
Knight captures an E5 is by no means
force uh here you could also Play Bishop
captures on A6 and then it's also a very
fun line Rook captures an A6 and now
Knight cap address on E5 Bishop captures
an H3 now Knight captures an F7 a nice
captive effects going on here now Knight
the G4 going after the F2 Pawn G
captures an H3 attacking the Knight here
Bishop captures an F2 with check King G2
now Bishop captures an E1 and now after
Knight captures on the eighth Bishop
captures and G3 and now King captures on
G3 and look at this uh complete mess
here uh for example you you save your
Knight Knight to F6 now Queen to D3
guards the Knight on uh d8 and it's uh
it truly is a a mess of a position it
looks like you're gonna lose the Knight
because of Rook T8 but then there's
Queen to C4 with check the Knight comes
the E6 and so on uh but basically the
line has been uh or thoroughly analyzed
and it it deals nothing more than a draw
so here are queen to C7 by ding keeping
the tension and now we have Bishop back
to A2 and here on Apple I really did
spend his time he has to consider a lot
of moves here like he has to considered
Bishop D3 which is kind of nice because
after let's say captures and captures
you get the C5 Square for your knight
but white already made a nice Rook lift
here he can move the knight uh get the
Knight to F5 the rook and go to F3 to G3
put pressure on the black king and so on
another thing you could do instead of
this bishop tape you always put the
Knight H4 right away go for Knight to F5
but nipple says all right let's uh you
know keep it cool let's go Bishop day
two uh and now uh we just wait and see
what's being plays we basically we're
waiting for his move and while there are
many ways ways ding could continue this
as the B5 score is no longer controlled
by Anne's Bishop ding just strikes would
be five uh and okay Queen to E2 putting
pressure on the pawn Here and Now link
played Rook to B8 and here uh Anand in
the live coverage um I said he didn't
really like this Rook to B8 uh idea
because it kind of leaves the Knight
undefended here if the bishop ever moves
could be a problem uh and also that
White's moves are are sort of easy to
find and blacks are are not the the move
that uh ding probably considered but
didn't play his Bishop to f8 and it's
such a beautiful line that we have to
check it out as it comes with a pawn
sacrifice here but if white goes for it
and it is objectively the best uh a
white has captures captures and now
Queen captures on B5 now you play
Knights the C5 and after let's say B4
because why not uh Knight to D3 attacks
the rook and after Rook the D1 Bishop A6
and black gets a lot of very nice
developing moves in let's say queen
captures on A5 Queen capture than C3 and
it's a very
interesting position but the problem is
again as it is with all interesting
positions that let's say Bishop to D2
Queen to C2 and now rotate the C1 uh you
can sort of uh force a draw here let's
say Knight captures real captures and
after uh Queen to B2 uh you can just
repeat Rook to B1 Queen to C2 Rook to C1
and so on the queen never wants to come
to D3 that's kind of the issue here
because there's always this bishop
captures on F7 check move and now you
can't capture back because of Knight
captures an E5 check picking up the
black queen so it's a a complete mess of
a position but basically with perfect
play it yields nothing more than a draw
I kind of feel saying the silly saying
that because all positions are like that
but I mean uh it's just incredible that
such a such a mess of a position can uh
it can just you know be traded down to a
simple draw but okay Rook to be inviting
uh he puts the Rook here to defend the B
Pawn and now Knights the H4 by nepo now
nepo wants to put an item 5 and sort of
start an attack against the black king
Bishop to fate now and now Queen to F3
now you could also consider a knight to
G6 as of course the F Pawn is pinned but
it's not anything spectacular the bishop
will just move and uh okay the Knight is
on G6 but it's nothing nothing fun to
look at so okay after Bishop to f8 Queen
to F3 nepo just mounts the pressure we
have uh now B captures on each uh uh uh
an A4 uh Bishop captures an H6 never
offers a full Bishop now but it only
seems that way because if you accept
this uh then you you go into all sorts
of problems let's say G captures and H6
Queen captures an F6 now what do you
play if you attack the queen let's say
Bishop to G7 then there's this very
nasty idea of Bishop captures and F7
check and you can't capture because of
uh Queen captures Rook here and other
moves aren't all that better because
you've just lost all of your defenses in
front of the black king so your best
defense would be Rook to D6 to get the
Rook out of harms away and also defend
um the the the the pawn here and also
Queen to G6 check is no longer a problem
uh but now you will see a queen captures
an E5 and again uh it's It's Tricky but
better for white if root capture some B2
you can even play Bishop to C4 and now
if Rook captures an F2 which is kind of
what you want to play now if uh the king
captures Rook the D2 check will pick up
the White Queen but you can just play
Knight to G to F5 and everything is fine
white is white will always be better if
Rook D to D2 you're just gonna play
Queen to F6 and keep mounting the
pressure If Bishop captures on F5 You're
Gonna Play e characters and F5 and now
you have to bring the Rook back with
Rook to D6 but it's not a problem again
just Bishop captures an F7 with check
Queen captures and now Queen captures on
F7 King captures and King captures and
F2 uh leaves you with this position
where uh White is up the exchange Four
Points each so white uh has excellent
winning chances here uh so that being
said uh after Bishop captures on H6
Knights the C5 was played by ding and
this is in fact the the best way to go
about it uh we ignite the G6 Now by
Nepal you could also consider Bishop to
G5 and also I know as you guys are very
much interested in this move Bishop
captures and G7 looks like a fine idea
but after Bishop captures on G7 there's
Queen to E3 uh bringing the queen into
the attack also putting pressure on the
Knight here and now once you save the
Knight Queen to G5 and now after Knight
captures an E1 you're probably thinking
okay now Knight G2 F5 we Checkmate black
but not really there's Bishop captures
on F5 and after Knight captures just
Knight back to EA to defending the
bishop here and now you don't really
have a way of uh winning if Knight to
each six check you're just gonna move
the king and if Knight captures an F7 uh
hoping uh you know it works because
let's not forget about our good friend
the bishop here then Knight goes back
Knight to D3 and black is just up too
much material you have zero compensation
here as white but of course I know you
guys are interested in uh this move so
uh we had to check out but instead
Knight E6 was played by nepo and now
ding plays Rook captures on B2 uh it's a
move okay you can consider Rook captures
on B2 and The Rook to D3 to attack the
queen Rook to D3 I will also show it
because it's a lot of fun is met with
Rook to E3 and now if Rook captures on
B2 you're gonna play Rook captures on D3
Knight captures and now even Queen
captures on D3 G captures on H6 Knight
captures an f8 King captures an f8 and
now Bishop to C form you can see how
there are a lot of captures here and
there is certainly a lot to calculate
here but in the end okay black does have
the the past Pawn here but it can only
be white who's better look at that black
king um the the the defenses in front of
him have been messed up uh not not fun
to play so instead just Rook captures on
B2 by ding uh situation on the clock if
you guys are interested one hour for
nepo in 48 minutes for ding so and
nipple again I I had on time but now
after Knight captures an f8 and this
Rook captures an f8 move never played
Bishop to G5 and he he definitely spent
his time here he could consider some
other moves like Queen to E3 going after
the Knight then the Knight goes back and
so on but he decided just to threaten
Bishop captures and F6 and here he spent
quite a lot of time they're actually 47
minutes both uh on the clock now night
stage seven of course ding will not
allow nipple to ruin his Pawn structure
Bishop to C1 chases away the rook and
now Rook the B5 and now comes the bishop
to A3 uh pinning the Knight here you
could also consider Bishop to C4 it's a
fine idea but it will be met with Bishop
T6 that's the problem and I think that
Jan knows this that Ding with a very a
very uh happily allowed Bishop captures
on B5 followed by C captors creating
this beautiful Pawn Mass on the queen
side but here we would probably see
something like Bishop to F1 and now Rook
after B8 and the the game continues
nothing spectacular here but in instead
Bishop to A3 by nipple now comes Rook to
E8 so the Knight can now move and Bush
up to C4 but again ding just goes Bishop
to E6 he says you you can take my Rook
here I I'm very much looking forward to
fixing my Pawn structure and then
creating some pass pawns on the queen
side but of course uh nepo doesn't do it
he just plays Bishop captures on E6 and
this is the the best way to play now
it's 28 minutes for nepo and actually 40
minutes for ding I don't know if this is
the first time uh but you know it could
be the first time that Ding has a
significant time advantage on the clock
so 20 to 40 minutes 13 more moves to be
made for time control to be reached we
have Knight captures on E6 uh you have
to consider other captures as well but
Knight captures definitely makes sense
as you want to bring that Knight
uh deeper into the position and also you
want to advance the spawn at the C5 and
the C4 and so on so here at night to F5
another a move that um uh you can
consider is Queen D1 because what's up
with the A4 Pawn uh seems like if uh I
had never played Queen 31 Dean would
have the part with this A4 Pawn because
if he tries to defend it then this is
met with Bishop to D6 attacks the bishop
attacks D5 Pawn attacks the A4 pawn and
nepo could get some serious Advantage
here uh but okay Knight to F5 was played
and now we have Pawn to C5 uh we have
Queen to E2 now putting pressure on The
Rook here and Rook the B3 uh Queen to C4
now uh it's a very nice Square for the
queen just pressuring that A4 Pawn again
uh here 28 minutes for both on the time
um uh and the 10 more moves that we made
for time control to be reached with
Queen to C6 defending the A4 pawn and
now this should be back to C1 uh we have
Knight to F6 ding brings his Knight back
into the game and now comes Queen
capture than A4 if you try Rook captures
on A4 then you allow Rook captures on C3
in between move and then it's very
annoying if you trade let's take Queen
capture so the queen captures then black
has the the two pawns here okay let's
say F3 defense D for pawn queen to B4
and this is very very uh hard to play
for white as the the two uh pass pawns
will will be hard to stop uh so instead
after F6 Queen captures an A4 was played
now comes Queen captures with Rook
captures on A4 and Rook captures and C3
Rook captures on C3 is by no means
mandatory because you of course know
that Bishop to B2 is coming and you will
lose the E5 Pawn but there's no no
better alternative for example if Knight
to F4 we're just gonna trade here
captures captures Now Pawn to E5 attacks
the Knight let's unite the D7 and now
you're gonna trade real captures and F4
row captures on C3 and you uh save the F
Pawn a d Pawn uh black still has the two
past pawns but white should be able to
you know to handle them uh so uh that's
why Rook captures in C3 was played uh
and now Bishop to B2 attacks The Rook
Rook to B2 and Bishop captures an E5
with rooked a B4 now uh offering a rook
trade and now of course Rook captures an
A5 we have Rook captures on e4 uh
trading pawns basically Rook captures an
E4 Knight captures on e4 and now Rook to
A4 putting pressure on the Knight here
uh 21 minutes each so it's not a problem
as only two more moves need to be made
for time control to be reached with
Knight to D4 uh and here
that thing is basically saying I don't
want to deal with all of this pressure
you have against my G7 Pawn then and
also attacking the Knight maybe The Rook
can come help out with the attack if I
move the Knight you can play Rook to A7
I put pressure this way if for example I
play something like F6 so uh not that
the best ding decides to give up a pawn
in order to stop the attack and he will
try and hold this being down upon so
Knights the D4 was played Bishop
counters on d4c captures and now Rook
captures on D4 with Pawn to G6 uh and
now Knight back to E3 and now it's 3.3
pawns against two I have a bishop and uh
of Knight in The Rook still in the game
so of course you guys know that
objectively this is a draw but uh the
players will still still play it out
with King to G7 Rook the
um uh Rook to B4 and now Knight to G3
ding tries to force a draw right away
because if of course captures then
captures and uh again it's a draw only
without Knights on the board so nepo
goes for Rook to B7 he will try to to
put some pressure on that F7 phone
Knight the F5 even offers Knight
captures on F5 but even this messed up
structure for ding is an is an easy draw
for him ending knows this Nepal knows
this so of course nepo doesn't trade he
plays Knight to G4 we have Rook to E7
now offering a rook trade and Rook to B5
nipple hat and he's upon of course he
will try to squeeze it as much as
possible we have rooked E1 with Chuck
King to H2 now comes Rook to E2 and The
Rook to B7 just keeping the tension on
the seventh rank uh Knight to D6 and now
Rook to A7 we have King to f8 and now
King to G3 and here was a very uh very
possible uh way for uh for one of the
players to blunder the game he never
played Rook to D7 then ding could
consider a move like Pawn to F5 uh sort
of sort of the trade Knights but also
there are some other moves that he could
consider but basically now if Rook
captures and D6 and F captures on G6 now
H4 is winning for white and that could
be could be a big issue for example King
to G7 King to G3 goes after the pawn and
now if um uh I mean what do you play
here it's a rook day two you move the
Rook so you can capture the F2 Pawn if
King captures on G4 but of course Rogue
D4 The Rook will be the one who captures
I have King F6 let's have real
characters on G4 now it's three pawns
against one and of course this is now
winning so it's one of the ways that um
it could go down but uh nepo just placed
King to G3 we have Pawn to F5 now now F5
is a good idea we have King to F3
attacks the rook and The Rook back to E7
nipple again doesn't trade he keeps the
Rooks on the board with Rook to A8 with
check uh Rook to E8 blocking and only
now trading Rook captures King captures
and not Knight to E5 now if nepo can
somehow get his King to G5 without ding
doing anything then it would be great
for him but that's just not how chess
works so here we have Pawn to G5
stopping any infiltrating ideas by the
white king and now Pawn to H4 this is um
a nice attempt with G captures and H4
and now King to F4 so he wins the F4
Square nonetheless and the players have
already reached time control they have
plenty of time so time is not an issue
here and there are two moves that uh
don't lose the game for the do you see
those what the two moves are without
even without pausing the video what
would you you know if I showed this to
you like what would you instantly play
there are like I said but two and uh one
of them was luckily played one of them
is King t7 the other one is Ponte H3 uh
the the point is that if King t7 uh you
will lose this Pawn Knight to G6 check
it will play King to F6 Knight captures
and this is uh still a draw it's nothing
spectacular uh but um he tried the other
way around he played Pawn to H3 if you
play Knights the E4 this is another move
that he could have tried which would
have cost him the game because now yes
you're attacking the pawn here but after
Knight D3 defending the pawn let's say
you go back to defend the F5 Pawn now
King E5 attacks the Knight and if King
E7 defending now Knight to F4 is a a big
problem uh now Knight E4 attacks the
pawn now F3 and if Knight back to D6 now
we're just gonna play Knight to G6 with
check King to D7 and now Knight captures
on H4 with captors on F5 next and you're
gonna be up two pawns so Knights the E4
would be terrible here however King D7
and H3 are okay for the ding play Pawn
to H3 as he will lose the pawn either
way G captain with King the E7 and not
Knight the C6 with check with King to F6
and now Knight to D4 so now both players
basically know it's a draw but you
always have that one percent chance that
maybe it's that's some sort of a
spectacular position where maybe uh
White has a mating 127 you just don't
know when you play I mean no if no one
knows at all uh so here Knight's the E4
we have F3 Knight to F2 going for the
pawn and the H4 nip of course will
advance his past Pawn Knight to D3 with
checking G3 King to G6 and Knight to E6
we have King to F6 Knight to F4 offering
a trade and knights the B4 ding just
declines of course you do not want to go
into a king and pawn and game being done
upon uh King F2 King E5 King to E3 and
Knight the C2 King D2 and not Knights
the D4 uh you could also trade uh
capture uh King captures and F4 is
possible and this will again be a
drawable captran F3 while it will start
marching forward but it's still gonna be
a draw
a fine draw but uh a very instructive
one for uh for example for those of you
who are new to chess this will be the
position and the black will have a pass
Pawn Advanced all the way to the at the
seventh rank or the second Rank and uh
for those of you who don't know yes this
is a draw black cannot promote this Pawn
the problem is once the White Queen
gives all the checks uh here one final
check will be given and you will not
play King to F1 uh to allow white to
start bringing the white king closer you
will play King to H1 threaten promotion
and now only now once white captures it
will be a draw by stalemate the black
king has no move so that's the problem
but okay no need to calculate that far
just Knight to D4 we have a nice
repetition here Knight to D3 check king
of six King to E3 Knights the C2 check
and King to F4 we have Knight to D4 King
G3 Knight d8 King F2 Knight to D for
Knights the F4 and the king the E5 so
not nothing spectacular here 92 again
declining the trade the king G3 King F6
King G2 King G7 King F2 and now Pawn to
F4 yeah I think is feeling very
confident about the spawn push King G1
King G6 King G2 King h691 King H5 King
H3 Knights to D4 Knight to D3 and now we
have a a capture finally Knight captures
on F3 Knight captures an F4 with check
and he was in this position on move 82
at that dingler and the only Punisher
agreed to a draw as there is nothing
more to be done here a few more moves
will be played let's say King H6 uh Pawn
to H5 but there is no way to advance the
pawn further uh for more moves and the
Knight Will capture the pawn let's say
something like this the Knight will go
all the way to G7 and then King H3
Knight captures on H5 will be a draw by
insufficient material
uh so yeah very interestingly very
interestingly done so it's uh it's
interesting that uh for the first half
of the match uh being uh sort of
resorted to the uh to the amorphous
defense the A6 against the real Lopez
but here he went for the Berlin defense
uh even though he's down in the match by
a point so that's that's very
interesting sort of um uh the the idea I
believe behind it is he wants to be
solid with black not allow nepo any
winning chances and look for his chances
with the white pieces as with the white
pieces he's been getting some uh some
excellent positions if you haven't seen
the previous video of game eight that
being just uh played a brilliant
brilliant game and he missed a beautiful
win uh do check it out I I definitely
recommend it uh but yeah this is game
nine uh we'll see what happens in the
next one where ding will again have the
white pieces uh what will they what will
team uh Team Ding and team Erica rapper
come up with uh I can't wait to see
because so far they've they've been uh I
mean they've been incredibly
entertaining and I mean playing some
incredible chess uh so yeah that's the
game I hope you guys enjoyed it uh like
I said look very much looking forward to
game 10 tomorrow is the rest day so the
day after tomorrow we continue uh I
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to Costa and I would like to thank Scott
McRae Max Sally ravishing reptiles
YouTube and Ricky black for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
World Chess Championship until it
finishes uh thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day